les collégiens et les lycéens ne devrait
pas avoir cours à 8h 8h30 même 9 heures
puisque on sait à partir de
l'adolescence ils vont avoir un décalage
de l'horloge biologique ils vont devoir
se coucher plus tard on peut
difficilement lutter contre ça le
problème c'est qu'ils vont devoir se
lever exactement à la même heure que
tout le monde une expérimentation a été
menée aux états unis on fait aller les
enfants à l'école une heure plus tard
n'observer de meilleurs résultats
scolaires moins de bagarres à l'école
moins d'accidents de la route bref il
faut absolument qu à partir du collège
pour commencer à décaler l'heure des
premiers cours il faut avoir un vrai
courage de le faire est aussi acceptée
peut-être de finir un peu plus tard
l'école c'est ça ça vous de me dire si
vous êtes hockey alors qui est d'accord
avec ça c'est une question vraiment que
tout le monde s'oppose vous mêlez oui
oui parce que je me dis bah c'est un
médecin et l'horloge biologique des
enfants elle et elle évolue donc quand
ils sont aussi visiblement ça pose pas
de problème la donner à l'adolescent ça
devient plus compliqué donc s'adapter à
l'horloge biologique de l'enfant ça ne
me semble pas un contresens donc
pourquoi pas en revanche terminé plus
tard là pour le coup je suis pas
d'accord parce que regarder aux états
unis ou en angleterre l'après midi
plombée par jour moi je trouve que
l'année scolaire devrait être plus
longue tout simplement est ce un prénom
à la laquelle mauvaise idée en
angleterre et dans d'autres pays
l'après-midi disons aux jeunes à venir
on démarre l'école une heure plus tard
qu'en france et l'après midi ils ont le
sport la musique le théâtre etc alors il
ya moins de bagarres ayant moins
d'accidents de la route à moins de
consommation de produits dopants il ya
de meilleurs résultats scolaires voilà
il ya plus de morts
il ya plus de morts il ya une violence
incroyable dans les collèges américains
rapport avec la fatigue
moi j'ai rien compris à cette vidéo que
je trouve complètement démago fusé sur
titres mais c'est un réseau social prix
oui il améliore la douane mais c'est
diffusé sur tik tok vous avez plein de
jeunes qui disent ah trop bien on va se
réveiller plus tard l'ami suis désolé
l'école s'est dessinée ça sert à se
préparer aussi à la vie active ces gens
qui travaillent se lèvent à 7 heures à 6
heures voire plus tôt à 5h donc vois pas
pourquoi on ferait se lever les
adolescents plus tard si on veut les
adolescents 20 dorment plus maison qu'à
se coucher plus tôt voilà c'est juste
pour qu'ils puissent rester sur tik tok
et sur un stage qu'à 3 heures du mat
c'est complètement démago et sa série
non moi je suis pas d'accord en fait les
pressions énormes avec guillaume on a
une pression énorme toute notre vie et
tout depuis qu'on est né on 10 la
pression et watteau sinon demain tu vas
être fatigué moi je comprends je
comprends jim et moi même à un moment
donné on a dit wen a minima
grave grave c'est un ami et ouais donc
je me dis ouais on devrait avoir moins
la pression le soir parce que vous savez
que quand on sait qu'on se réveille tôt
le lendemain la pression telle heure on
dort le moi en fait ou sinon vous avez
souvent moi j'ai trop de pression à
votre oppression et donc du coup je me
dis que si on met moins l'impression aux
enfants mais du coup le moment ils sont
plus éveillés plus actifs ils ont plus
envie d'aller à l'école parce qu'ils se
sont réveillés une heure plus tard ils
ont eu moins de pression et la pression
ça joue énormément au quotidien
oui moi je suis pas d'accord et qui me
-1 m m'a réveillé là
parce que c'est absurde son raisonnement
ya bien évidemment éviter un ami quand
je vis mais il est formidable
enfin quelqu'un enfin quelqu'un et pour
une fois je suis d'accord unanime et
guillaume n'importe quoi vous vous dites
oui oui moi je suis team jimmy mohamed
genou qu'il a raison alors c'est pas la
peine de faire ta des ados à la maison
la maison il à moi
ou à la maison et je constate au
quotidien qu'effectivement ça un rythme
qui ne leur convient pas parce que quand
tu es à dos tu peux pas leur imposer de
se coucher à 8h30 donc forcément il
commence la journée avec un manque de
sommeil et donc c'est ridicule ça sent
il faut tout remettre à plat je trouve
que les enfants en france il travaille
trop et trop mal il faut il faudrait
qu'ils travaillent le matin et
l'après-midi stop on fait du sport on
fait autre chose et tu es vraiment je
trouve que c'est mal foutu en france ils
font deux heures de sport par semaine le
sport à prix revient au cours de maths
et puis la transpiration et aucune
hygiène mais c'est catastrophique
la transpiration bas les enfants les
ados difficiles encore jeune et frais
mais quand il sera plus grand et
beau toit va me toi je te dis qu'il me
bat donc du regard et non moi je ne veux
pas je ne veux pas qu'on termine plus
tard plus tard ça veut dire que l'hiver
il fait nuit fait froid dangereux c'est
pas bien c'est pas bien tu avais vu les
résultats de nos écoles en france ah non
mais ça c'est un autre nom mais ça c'est
un autre débat l'armée sur le rythme
scolaire là c'est un autre débat ça veut
dire qu'il faut travailler autrement
mieux non non et moi je suis pour que
les enfants continuent à cette heure-là
le matin et que ça termine comme ça
termine quatre heures 5 heures ou 18
heures mais plus tard c'est impossible
de les faire en
transport en commun plus tard la fille
ma fille apprend le bus en rentrant du
collège ne va pas prendre le bus à 19
heures à 20 heures canon donc être en
reste comme ça dit mohamed pour cette
fois il aurait mieux fait de se taire
mais
vraiment non moi je suis papou pour
qu'on commence plus tard va quoi sinon
ça y est
[Rires]
on n'est que mardi tueur plongeant soyez
gentils mais ouais on est à dakar où il
avait il a brisé quatre jours deux par
semaine trois jours on savait que le
jeudi est un petit peu fatigué dérapé à
la maintenance
combien ça commence à la tu vas arrêter
très tôt
non parce que je dis que voilà on est on
fait des enfants rois moi je pense que
les collégiens et les initiants les
collégiens c'est quoi ces 11 ans et 12
ans ils dorment pas assez bas 21h ils
vont au lit ils arrêtent les réseaux
sociaux il a raison
ils vont toucher pas si folle et
resserrer un peu un moment donné tu peux
pas dire parce que vous pensez pas tout
l'encadrement vous dites c'est facile
ils vont finir plus tard donc le centre
aéré plus tard la nana qui doit aller
chercher ses enfants elle qui avait s
qui est qui et qui fait du centre aéré
qui as m qu'est ce qui a fait rentrer
chez elle à quelles heures à 19 heures
d'un canard va chercher ses propres sens
et je ne voulais vous pensez à ce que
tous sous l'encadrement faut subir on va
vivre qui finissent à 19 heures il ya
des transports faut penser aux petites
villes parce que là on pense grande
ville en bus mairie quand tu fais le
compte et non mais c'est ça un moment
donné il sert et jusque là vice de fond
aurait fermé de voir mes nord mais il a
finalement terminé même si ça commence
plus tard est que tu termines pas plus
tard evatt manqué cinq heures un moment
de danse m'a dit lui même baptisé cool
mais ces temps l'avionneur à fournir
l'école le 5 juillet tout fini l'école
le 10 juillet
hôtels et locations mais bella
l'estival le moment faire les gentils
dans le 10 juillet les gens doivent le
louer plus partir en vacances je ne peux
pas mais aujourd'hui les ministres
mais sans balle bien ça vous dit selon
lui la séance oui c'est pas si simple tu
fais non a fait des zones singh
s'exprimait pour le tourisme qu'on a
fait des autres
alors on privilégie quoi le sourire des
enfants le tourisme alors on essaie de
faire un compromis ah le con chronique
le compromis 21h39 kouchner avait pas
[Applaudissements]
mais pas dire à mon épouse pas mon fils
il était alors vingt trois arrêts
mauvaise sortie comme un des bons trucs
sont
mélangés à des gamins et l'horloge
biologique elle était déjà là avant ma
poche alors on est crevé comment on
n'est pas
moi je péter la forme à emma intervilles
on avait interdit mais
bon sur bois saint thibault park zoo
mais bon c'est vrai quoi franchement
arena d'abord des horreurs comme ça ça
prépare les enfants à la vie active j'ai
eu envie de le dire j'ai envie de le
lire sans votre avis ouais donc je le
dis ça prépare les enfants la vie active
quand on ferme à 7 heures du matin heure
parce qu'on dirait pas mais si grande
est une star mondiale où il ya un an
qu'il ya un encadrement tu vas pas
téléphoné à mon patron et dire mon fils
maintenant il travaille à 8 heures je
vais au plus tard demain rien dire tout
un encas sachant qu'il y aura vraiment
c'est pas ça comme ça c'est beaucoup de
respect pour monsieur dit me mohamed
mellah il a tort non il a mis c'est vrai
il ya toujours des gens c'est facile il
ya des gens c'est facile tu peux même
leur dire l'école à 10 heures ils
emmèneront leurs enfants quand même à 10
heures mais il ya des gens qui vont déjà
au boulot à 17h besoin de déposer le
dossier corse y en ad'autres a pas
besoin de tes parents mais là nous on
l'a 11 au 13 et maintenant des lycées
à la vie active à
la vie active aux états unis en
angleterre ça n'arrête pas mais non ça
leur est pas là
oui je dis comme vous ça n'a rien à voir
benhaim un avoir
j'ai par l'anglais savoir qu en
allemagne un commissaire en allemagne
par l'allemand oui oui mais c'est vrai
ça va vous très bien vous commencer
l'émission
[Rires]
sympa et que t'es sympa j'avais truc à
dire mais comme je n'ai pas la barbe à
la pression mettant en garde chez brady
w mais je pensais qu'à gauche d'enfants
plus il ya 30 ans effectivement connais
pas les raisons étaient couchés un des
derniers arrivants et paderborn
d'horloge biologique non effectivement
8h08 heure me après du sport voilà je
suis d'accord il fait une bêtise par
jimmy wales ne dis pas de bêtises
mais on n'a pas changé c'est son point
de vue s'il n'y pas une bêtise c'est son
poulailler l'avant dans vos quotidiens
il observe les états unis moi j'aimais
tant pis